everybody does Walker here just doing a
real fast review of movie it's a song
called get out maybe you've heard of it
is doing very very well the box office
and it's doing phenomenally well with
critics yeah last I checked is that a
hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes and I
know you're all checking in to see am I
gonna suck it stick to um big second uh
this is uh this is a good movie um so
just fast review there you go it's good
it is a good movie um am I gonna do what
people call the shitty Doug thing right
so it's not that good no it actually is
very very clever um it's in order to
talk to what's really good about it I
got going to spoilers so I'll go into
some detail first I'll let you know when
the spoilers are coming um but my first
thought when I saw this and I'm watching
you see the trailer for those who don't
know it's about a black guy a white
woman they go to visit her parents
they're dating and you know he just
wanted this you know if they're gonna
have a problem at all with him being
black you know anything is probably not
but you you just never know and on the
one hand it doesn't seem like it but
then things seem to get worse and worse
in this whole area is just very very odd
and obviously something is going on and
that's the most I can say in terms of
the plot so far before getting into
spoilers fruitball obviously you know
when you see the trailer it's pretty
much for the most part what you're going
to get like that is kind of the movie
there's not a ton of surprises but the
ones that they have are good and they
are what kind of separates us from just
being an OK film to a legitimately good
smart clever flick um but all the basics
are there the acting is good the writing
is pretty good the best part of the
movie in my opinion in terms of like man
this just this works like this is really
solid is when he first visits the
parents and the parents are all saying
things because they're both saying
things that are you're constantly go
is that meant to be taken a certain way
or not it is ingenious writing because
you really can't tell because like it's
something where if you told someone else
that somebody said this they'd be like
yeah so what that could easily be this
and everything is just the right amount
in that first day that he's there with
them and then from there it kind of goes
a little bit more to the okay this is
now the awkward everything that's being
said is just you know that uncomfortable
like obviously a white person does not
know how to talk to a black person way
of talking we're in the the first day
was what's the best writing in my
opinion and a bus so the acting is
because the writing is good there's nice
little touches that catch you a little
off-guard like their stuff with
hypnotism in this that it's done in a
very unique way again I won't give it
away but the way that's done is very
effective both visually and in the idea
of it um and I say there's just enough
little surprises to get to keep you
interested because that's my big fear
going is that I would just know what
this was and just wait for it all to
play out but I think sort of the writing
and these situations that you recognize
you know sometimes they go a little much
is such as it keeps going but again it's
kind of a horror film commentary satire
and stuff like that so so all of that is
going to be playing into it it's a
Jordan Peele movie though surprisingly
the comedy is play down a little bit
more than you might think it's for the
most part done like a straightforward
it's almost hard to even say a horror
film might almost say thriller but but
when you see what all is at the end is
like yeah okay you can say horror film
it can kind of follow Danny category
it's either both categories I should say
um so yeah it's it's a good flick but to
go into what's really really good about
it I got now going to the spoiler
section so here's the big thing I
thought as I think a lot of people
thought that it was going to be the
black people that come to this place
because a lot of them
kind of like you know Elmo servants to
them or they see much more like this one
guy was sort of taken away and then he
comes back very for like a better term
very white you know as they're talking
like these upscale old white people and
such and you think like they're being
hypnotized like you know the white
people want to emphasize them it could
be more white and stuff that's not
what's going on what is going on I think
elevates this to a new level in just in
terms of conversation in terms of what
what you can do with this is uh the
white people the older white people are
actually having their brains put into
these black bodies into these black
heads and there's only a little shrivel
of the black person still left in there
and it's that just adds a whole new
layer ah you know could you get at it's
about I mean you could say like yeah
it's technically racism but it's like
they want to be the black people that's
kind of it and they want them for
different reasons they want be them
because they see em is physically more
athletic than whites the income CCM is
more beautiful there's one you know it's
constantly looking in the mirror and
just loves how she looks and stuff like
that there was one that what to because
he's more artistic and even a guy at one
point just as I don't know why they pick
black people I couldn't give a I
just know you have a great artistic
artistic eye and you know and then the
conversations like you know one guy
clearly being super awkward it's like
yeah black seems to be very in and
that's when you kind of go into the
alright this was a little much but it
it's service different love because a
lot of these movies about race is they
just sort of stop at you know yeah
hating whatever race it is you know
these people hate these people some go
into better explanations of why um and
you know like Zootopia was very clever
with that um I hate using this
comparison crash the ideas they were
talking about are very legit the way
they do what are very pretentious and
in-your-face and that well done but see
the idea is still very solid of where in
their kind of racist and
stuff like that come but always cat
comes from just them putting down and
hating and stuff like that this comes
from a new level this comes from it's
like an appreciation and a wanting to
control a wanting to dominate because
they secret rule they secretly really
appreciate that kind of stuff and you
look at it so much I mean especially
America because that's a hodgepodge of
culture and diversity and we see how
much has been taken from so many
different groups and races and stuff I
do kind of feel like that is relevant
and that is kind of a new take on this I
think is very legit um so and I can kind
of see through like in these guises or
these people's minds they're like well
we we like this race the way we
appreciate so much more so clearly what
we're doing is not races I mean it's
wrong and it's evil but but it's not
racist because I always feel that like
the big number one thing that people
don't want to be because it's like
immediate hypocrite if your label that
or or sexist or any kind it this so
nobody really wants to be that but the
ones that are always find a way of
wording it or making it sound like
that's not what they're doing um so
again you can kind of see this line up
where it's like they know they're doing
something bad but it's not race as bad
except they're cooking it because they
actually really appreciate it they
appreciate the race so I mean yeah we're
you know taking these people's freedom
away from them and putting our brains
inside this Center in many respects
killing them but you know it we're doing
it because we like them so on that
aspect we're cool we're actually not
racist at all so it's a very funny
interesting spin I thought that was a
really really cool and in many respected
almost it's weird because it's like it's
about race and it's not which I think
makes a very interesting connection to
all of this is that is kind of about
power and control and just having sort
of like dominance over something and you
know but why is it always you know would
be these black people because they see
you know something to admire and that's
something that they want so it's like
yes it is about power and control
you know and you could say like so
example racism it's about power control
but our thing kinda the same isn't there
like a super strong crossover so uh this
movie is very very clever and kind of
forcing you to talk about this kind of
stuff and I if you're like me you kind
of see a lot of movies that talk about
any kind of prejudice how it's bad um
you know and just don't do it and so on
so forth and it's one of those things we
can't roll your eyes and say yes we know
the Fern Gully Pocahontas you know like
all these things of like you know that
not for avatar in this case that I guess
you can almost argue for in Fergalicious
pure environment
um but yeah but certainly avatar and you
know info guys and all these stories
before a million times prejudice equals
bad and it usually just kind of stops
there they don't analyze it they don't
look into it and it's so frustrating
when they don't do it because it's like
you know what you know you're trying to
teach that an entire people aren't bad
you know and by doing that you're just
bad you're not explaining it you know
there is so much more it is so much more
interesting and when a movie that
doesn't try to explain it just tries to
say what are they going to learn that
you know there's no such thing it's just
good people and bad people when you do
that that's just bad you're bad people
when you do that it's like this you're
immediately going against your own
message when you do that so in my saying
this does like there clearly are people
doing bad things but the mindset is very
fascinating and I think that's where
movies about kind of like any kind of
prejudice whether it's a race or
whatever any kind of prejudice becomes
really interesting so this does take an
interesting angle in terms of like a
horror film or a psychological thriller
and stuff it is good but but it's not
great I wouldn't say this is like one of
the great horror films in terms of how
most horror films are
or even kind of thrillers are done
because there are a few of things that
don't always add up there there's a
brother character in this that like with
that whole scene the whole first day
with the parents and it's just so subtly
done and then just this guy come saying
he's just a pure nut any and he's the
brother easy in that line right here
yeah we put you ahead lock and stuff and
it's like what you're doing so subtle
there why throw that in there's kind of
a comic relief with this TSA guy who I
say about half the time is funny the
other half it's like okay we just need
some levity but which I get but it is
kind of distracting there are some
people that do want it to just be like
let's really submerge ourselves in this
deep dark uncomfortable place you know
and this doesn't do that it does go kind
of comedic angle but you could argue the
comedy is already kind of there in the
commentary and what they were saying and
even the idea so you know I feel like he
didn't need the the TSA guy um and I
will also say in the ending uh everyone
I can just tell you everyone thought
they knew how this was going to end
um because it's cursed with this cop
pulling him over the cop that seemingly
does not seem connected to anything
that's going on he's he's just a legit
douche and he even though the woman was
driving in a little like hit a deer or
something that he had for the boyfriend
driver's license and she's the one
Senate and no what do you mean he she
was gonna do it whatever like just just
gonna do it and if she's standing up and
saying no what was this what's
going on and stuff like that and he
eventually just was fine he doesn't look
at the license and walks away
immediately you think you know where
this is going to go where all the way
people are together or this crazy group
at leaves of like crazies are against
him and he's going to fight his way out
and the cops are going to come they're
gonna arrest him or shoot him and are
going to believe the white people like
you did your melee thing you know where
this is going to go and it doesn't quite
go that route they make it think it's
going to go that route but they don't if
anything they do it a little
a little bit more like a punch line um
which I like I just fear coming and I
like that it didn't go the route that
you just from the first frame you think
you know where it's going to go so I
like that but it's not hugely different
it's not like oh you got me and stuff
it's one of those things where you just
going to go okay um so so it's not where
I was going to go but there's nothing
that like all of that makes it so much
more powerful that makes the message or
that makes the TWiT so much more great
it's more just kind of playing with an
idea that you saw you know where it's
going to go you don't but it's not
really like you don't stand up and go on
yeah no you got me that's just totally
thrown me for a loop it's just oh you
didn't go that direction nice kind of
thing um so yeah I think this is a very
good very clever film uh it's not a film
that necessarily like grabs me it's not
something I'm like I'm guessing it's
like eight nine times or anything like
that even though there are things that
come back a lot of things do end up
coming back you know stuff in the
pictures and stuff all that is very
clever um but but it is very good it's
very clever and it is done more like a
straightforward horror film uh if you're
if you're almost people like me you kind
of almost look for things to nitpick
they're there I mean it's not a perfect
movie I think 100 percent is a little
extreme I don't write the meals work
that doesn't mean that everybody is
giving it like five out of five stars or
whatever you know I know that it's you
know some people can like it just enough
and if they all like it just enough that
means a hundred percent
um yeah but still I feel like there's
definitely stuff here that's either a
little awkward doesn't quite work
usually with the comedy surprisingly
there's a seaman si si guy goes to tell
the cops about this and it goes on way
too long and so and that's surprising
because that's Jordan Peele you know
obviously I'm known for comedy um but
it's pretty solid it's a very smart
movie that'll get you talking and it
will get you talking in
about in just the right way and just the
right amount I think it's it is clever
it has enough of us spin on it that I
think it opens up the conversation not
to a point where it's just sort of like
one-sided and you know prejudice bad and
that's it
you know it actually does go a little
bit more into it in a fun creative way
so yeah that's my take on it there's
definitely a little difficult response a
it's not a flawless film like you know a
lot of people are saying but I think the
idea and the commentary is so clever
that I think it's sort of overshadowing
all the other little things uh it which
is not necessarily bad you know it's
kind of fun having a film like this and
then doing so well I think I'm so cool
that a comedian is doing a scary film a
mostly psychological theory film and
it's a hit you know and this is his
first flick so I think that's pretty
cool I think that's really really neat
so um yeah that's about it it is
definitely a good film we're checking
out makes a lot of interesting
conversation and you know little Easter
eggs that you find hidden and stuff like
that so it's fun it'll get you talking
and it's got some creepy stuff in it and
that's about it I'll just see yeah
whatever the next flick is they'll
probably see probably Logan things
coming out next week I look forward to
seeing that so I will see you guys at
that one Lena